Ukraine says it's conducted a successful
operation after a fire broke out at a
military base in Russian Annex Crimea
that was days after explosions damaged
the Kirch Bridge linking the peninsula
to Russia authorities have not said what
may have started the blaze at the
military base in the karovsky district
Russia media has reported detonations
were heard Julius the latest now from
Moscow and Yulia any more clarification
from the Russian authorities about what
happened at the space
yeah some fast reactions are coming in
now from crimea's local authorities uh
russian-appointed governor of Crimea
Sergey accionov said that at the moment
no victims have been reported and
civilian infrastructure is not damaged
either the uh the causes of the fire
will be investigated by the authorities
of course while they had all the Crimean
Parliament said it would take a day or
two to battle the consequences of the
fire at the Ammunition Depot so as you
mentioned the military intelligence of
Ukraine claimed responsibility for the
fire they called the incident a
successful operation in the occupied
Crimea they have said the Russian side
is hiding the scale of the damage and
the number of of losses in Manpower that
according to chief of the Ukrainian
intelligence kiril budanov and as we
understand the detonation of ammunition
continues at the firing range in the
kirovski district of Crimea right now
it's this is the eastern part of the
peninsula a powerful fire continues
raging on more than 2 000 people are
being evacuated from four Villages of
the district reportedly the residents
will spend a day away from their homes
and after that it's planned they will be
allowed to return a part of the tavrida
highway around the area is called and
off right now it's blocked and uh
private and public transport is being
redirected to other roads while the
railway service continues working so the
operational headquarters have been
deployed and residents evacuated from
the from the fire area at the firing
range in Crimea are being assisted and
people will be provided with everything
necessary that's according to Governor
Axion officer authorities do not report
as you mentioned what caused the fire
and the explosions but earlier in the
social media in social networks they
reported about some explosions in the
sky and about some work of the of air
defense systems and Crimea says it will
cope with the situation without any help
from other regions
thank you